[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
Today, Claudio and I, Alain,
are going to talk about
writing your first
.NET application
using Google Drive.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
So you probably know already
because we had these videos in
the past two weeks.
We added a new Quickstart page
to the Google Drive SDK
documentation.
It's developers.googl
e.com/drive/quickstart.
On that page, you can find
step-by-step instructions on
how to write your first command
line application for
five support languages.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Six
languages now.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Actually six.
We Just added Go.
So we have Java, Python, PHP,
.NET, Ruby, and Go.
And we have videos covering
the Quickstart guide for
Python and PHP.
If you are interested in those,
you can find them in
our video library.
But today, we're going
to focus on .NET.
And you're going to see that
most of the introductory steps
are the same.
So if we go to the documentation
page at
developers.googl
e.com/drive/quickstart, we'll
see that we have five
steps to follow.
The first one is enabling
the Drive API.
So to do that, we have to
go to the APIs console.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
This has to be done with most
of our Google APIs.
So new developers or existing
developers who already have an
API project need to go to the
APIs console and enable the
APIs we want to use.
In our case, that would
be the Drive API.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we
go to the APIs console.
And if you have never created a
project before, you will see
this screen with a big blue
button saying Create Project,
which is what we're doing.
We need to create a project
to get credentials, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we
do Create Project.
We wait for a project
to be created.
And then we have a list of
services we want to enable.
The only one we need
is the Drive API.
So we scroll down to Drive, and
click on it to enable it.
So now your Drive API is enabled
for this project.
And we have a limit of 500,000
requests per day, which should
be more than enough for
today's example.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: For a
first application, yes.
But if you ever run out of
quota, there is a form on the
API console that you can fill,
and we will review the quota
requests and grant more quota or
get back to you to get more
information.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So once we
enable the Drive API, we have
to generate our credentials,
client ID, and client secret
for the OAuth 2.0 flow.
So we have to go to the
API Access tab.
In the API Access tab, we have
a big blue button that says
Create an OAuth 2.0 client ID.
It's pretty easy.
We just click on that.
We have to specify
our product name.
We can call it Drive
Quickstart.
It's up to you, adjust
the name.
And if you want, you can
add a product logo.
This is just a sample.
We don't have a logo, but you
can add it later if you want.
So I'm going to click Next.
And then you have to select if
you want a web application, a
service account application, or
an installed application.
So what we're going to write
today is a command line
application, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
So in--
[NO AUDIO].
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --iOS
or other, which
is everything else.
And ours is going to be other.
It's going to be a command
line application on .NET.
So you click on Create Client
ID, and you get your
credentials, which are the
client ID and the client
secret, which we're going to
need in our application.
They can be considered as
username and password.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Yes, but for--
[NO AUDIO]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --client
ID can be, let's
say, distributed around.
Other people can know about
your client ID.
Client ID of your application,
that's not secret.
But a client secret is
actually secret.
So if it happens that other
people get hold of your client
secret, you have to revoke
it and get a new one.
You can do that at any time by
going to the same page here
and clicking on Reset
Client Secret.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So let's say
at the end of this talk,
that's what I'm going to do.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
And if you ever reset your--
[NO AUDIO]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: If you reset
your client secret and
you still have it in your code,
the application will
just break.
The credentials would
not be accepted.
So let's go back to the Docs,
and we see that we've done the
first step.
It was very easy
and very quick.
So we enabled the Drive API
and we generated our
credentials for an installed
application.
The second step, it's
specific to the
language of your choice.
Because it's the step on how to
install the client library
for the language of a choice.
In our case, this is
going to be .NET.
There are similar instructions
for other languages.
The .NET one requires you to
download a zip with the
library and then reference
some of
those into your project.
So there's a link to the
core .NET library.
We can just follow the link.
It takes you to the
download page.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: The Drive
API is a simple REST API.
So if you already have an HTTP
client and you want to go
through the process for writing
your own HTTP client,
you can easily use the API.
But we do have supported client
libraries in many
languages, and it's so much
easier to use those.
And our documentations are
written together on those
client libraries.
So we recommend you using
those client libraries.
In case there are bugs, they'll
be easily fixed by us,
and they'll always be
up to date with
our most recent APIs.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Perfect.
So we're brought to the Google
API .NET client library page,
and what we want is the
latest stable release.
So we click on it, and we have
the option to download the
binary release, which includes
the DLLs, the source files, or
the samples.
What we need here is
the binary release.
So we just click on this and
we're going to download.
The file.
And it's done.
These ZIP files, which I'm
going to open now, will
include two folders, one for the
library, the core library,
and the other one
for the service.
So let me instruct this on my
desktop just to be used later.
So I'll copy this to
my desktop here.
You can obviously put the
files wherever you want.
And this will include many DLLs
you won't need because
we're only going to use Drive.
But if you check inside
Services, you will see a
folder for each API you can
use with this library.
So what we're going to
need is just Drive.
And if you check Lib, instead
you will see there's a number
of libraries we're going to
include in the next step.
So let's go back to
the documentation.
And we're done with
the second step.
So the third step is to
set up the sample.
Those instructions are also
specific for the language of
your choice.
So in .NET, we're going
to set up--
we're going to create a new
solution inside Visual Studio.
And then we're going to use
the code that's here.
So let's start with creating a
new solution in Visual Studio.
So I have Visual Studio
2010 open.
I can do New Project and select
Console Application.
Let's call this DriveQuickstart.
Obviously you can call
it as you want to.
I create a solution for this.
And it's an empty solution,
as you know.
What we're going to do here to
set up this is that we are
going to make sure we target
.NET Framework 3.5 or 4, not
Client Profile.
So we do right click on the
project and go to Properties.
The default framework for the
solution was .NET Framework 4
Client Profile.
We are going to change it
to .NET Framework 4.
3.5 is also valid.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
And I think the client library
also supports 2.5.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yes,
with some caveats.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So then we
need to add references to the
DLLs we want.
So we can do Add Reference
and select some
of the DLLs we want.
So let me browse the Lib
directory first.
So they were on my desktop.
So I can go to my desktop.
In here, there's a folder
called Lib.
What we need is DotNetOpenAuth.
We need Google.Apis.Auth
entication.OAuth2.
We need Google.Apis.
So we can start adding those.
We also need a reference
to the Drive service.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So we do
add another reference.
This is not here.
It's in the Service folder.
So we go back here, go to
Services, and we need Drive.
In the DriveService folder,
you will find two
DLLs for v1 and v2.
This sample is for v2, which
is mostly backward
compatible to v1.
There's just minor changes.
But now you should always use v2
if you start a new project.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: v2 is a
separate set of v1 and has
much more functionalities
than v1.
And if you already have
code working on v1,
it's easy to migrate.
And we do have a migration
guide on the
documentation page.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, I think
the migration from v1 to
v2 is just two very
easy steps.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes, changing
some attribute's
names and arguments.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So let's
go back to the code.
So we have this empty page.
But we can start from the
code we have here.
So we can take all of this
and then we will
explain it line by line.
So let me copy it.
I will copy this and replace the
content in my Program.cs
standard file.
This is that.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: All set.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: We can
build a solution.
Build succeeded.
We can run it.
Let's just add another
line here.
We're going to add it to
the documentation.
So you know, this is going to be
a command line application.
So when you run, it will
authenticate and then upload a
file to Drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: And close.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And close.
So if you want to see the
result, it's probably better
if we do a console.readline here
so that we just wait for
the user to press Enter.
And we need to add a file
to be uploaded to Drive.
So we're going to read
from the folder that
the executable is--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Running from.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --in.
So we can either manually add
the file to the debug
directory or wherever.
But it's probably better if we
add file from here and make
sure we copy it to the
content folder.
So we do Add.
We do Add New Item and search
for a text file.
This file is called
Document.txt.
If you want to use another
file, of course, you can
change it in the code.
But if we want to use the code
as it is, and we want to
follow the instructions step
by step, the file has to be
called Document.txt.
So we add it.
And we could write something
like this is a
test document, Save.
And then remember to make sure
this file is copied to the
output directory.
So you can change this--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Build rule.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --the build
rule to copy always.
So now if we run this
application, this
file will be there.
We just need another
exercise--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's right.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --which is
to set the credentials we
generated from the Google
APIs Console.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Right now,
if you run the application--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It will just
fail the authorization.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Because the
credentials are not valid.
We have two placeholders
here for client
ID and client secret.
So we can go back to the APIs
Console and copy those values
we generated.
So we take the client ID and
we replace this right here.
And then we take the client
secret and we
replace that too.
Now--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: We're
ready to go.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
So this will run a command
line application.
See what happens.
So I run and debug.
The first thing we do is the
authorization process.
So the application tries to
start a browser in your
computer to allow the user to
approve the application.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So this
application is requesting
permission to view and manage
the files and documents I have
on Google Drive.
If you want to know more details
about what we're
allowing the application to do,
you can expand it and see
a more detailed description.
The name you see here is the
name of the application, the
project we created in
the APIs Console.
So it's definitely my project.
I can allow access to it.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: And this
is what the users of our
application will see when
they go through the
authorization flow.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yes.
So since this is a command line
application this is not a
web application.
The flow is not the best for the
user as the users have to
copy this code from here and
pass it to the command line
application.
So I'm going to copy it from
here, go back to my shell.
As you can see, the application
is running here
and is waiting for me to provide
an authorization code,
which is the code we just
got from the flow.
So I can put the code here.
And what is going to happen
next, assuming the
authorization went well, and
I'm pretty sure it did, the
Document.txt file is going to
be uploaded to Google Drive.
And the application will
print the file ID.
So whenever you upload a file to
Google Drive, you get back
some metadata, including the
file ID, which is a unique ID.
And the file upload was
successful, and we got our
file ID, which is a long string,
and that's unique.
So now the application
is waiting for me to
press Enter to quit.
That's it.
The application worked.
And if I go to my Drive, I
should have a new document
called My Document, which
was just created.
And if I open it, it contains
the text I put,
this is a test document.
So it worked.
But you might wonder why this
is called My Document.
I mean, the file was called
Document.txt.
So, let's go back to the
code and check the
code line by line.
So in the code we have two
things to do, first,
authorization, second, use the
Drive API to upload a file.
The authorization
can be complex.
The OAuth flow can look
complex if you
don't know the details.
But the library hides all
the complexity from you.
So it's basically these
two lines here.
You need to instantiate
a provider and then
authenticator.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes, and
the library is also using
DotNetOpenAuth, which is an open
source library supporting
many types of authorization
mechanisms, including OAuth
2.0 OAuth 1.0 AuthSub,
and other protocols.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, so that
library is basically the
de-facto standard for OAuth
authorization in .NET.
And so we decided not to
reinvent the wheel and instead
we use a standard library that
almost everyone else uses.
So we use this library.
We extended it with our own
Google specific things.
And so you need to do
instantiate a new native
application client with your
client ID and secret.
And that's where the credentials
are used.
And then you have to instantiate
an OAuth
authenticator.
One of the parameter you pass to
the OAuth authenticator is
a function, in our case, called
GetAuthorization, which
is the function that the library
will automatically
call when the flow has
to be started.
So if we go down, here is the
GetAuthorization method, which
generates the authorization URL,
spawns the browser, and
waits for the user to--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Enter the code.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
--enter the code.
When that is done, it just
works on processing the
authorization with the code in
the client ID and secret and
all the other credentials
you have.
And that will return an object
which implements the
authorization state interface,
which is what we need to
instantiate the service.
So in fact, if we go back to
our main code, we can then
instantiate a DriveService using
the OAuth object we just
got from the authentication.
We're done with authorization.
Second part, we have to upload
a file to drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: How
do we do that?
Uploading a file requires
two parts, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
So a file in Drive, as Claudio
mentioned, has two parts, the
metadata and the content.
There are two types of files
actually, files that only
contain metadata for
applications who already has a
database and wants to sort the
content on the database.
We can simply create a shortcut
on Drive, and the
user would be able to see the
files on Drive and click and
be redirected to the
other applications.
Otherwise, the other form is
saving both metadata and
content on Drive.
And this will use the
user's quota.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And that is
exactly what we're doing here.
So we are setting some metadata
first, and then we
are setting the content.
As this is a sample,
we basically
hard-coded some metadata.
So the title would always
be My Document.
The description will always be
A Test Document, and the
MimeType will always
be text/plain.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: And
this is actually what
we saw on your Drive.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Yes, exactly.
Of course, if you want to
generalize this and make a
real application, you will
have to set the title
according to the real title or
give a user an option to
select a title and provide a
description, if any, and,
obviously, set the correct
mime type.
So this application will always
upload a text file to
Drive or assume that we're
trying to upload a
text file to Drive.
But if you want, let's say, to
upload a PDF, you have to
replace the mime type to
application PDF instead of
text/plain.
And this is all we need
for metadata and
then read the content.
So we use standard system.io
methods to read the content of
a file from our file system.
And here's where we see that
the application uses
Document.txt.
So if you want to obviously
give the user an option to
select a file, you have
to make this dynamic.
So instead of hard-coding the
name of the file, you give the
user an option to
select a file,
and with that a byteArray.
And then, it is just a single
line of code to
insert a file on Drive.
So we have this
InsertMediaUpload request
object which takes the
metadata and the--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Content.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --content as
a byte stream in the file
type, and then you can
call upload on it.
The upload, when that returns,
you will have a
response body property.
And the response body property
will include all the metadata
that is returned from Drive.
And that includes the file
title, the ID, the modified
data, a lot of information.
You can check what a file object
is to see what you get.
And eventually, before closing
the application, we just print
the file ID to show that the
application worked and we got
some metadata back.
And that's it.
We just wait for a user to
close and we're done.
So this main application, this
command line application, it
probably took 10 to 15
minutes to write.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: It does
everything from scratch, then
it does authorization and
uploading a file to Drive.
But, of course, you
can do more now.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
So the Drive API has many
functionalities.
So inserting files, as we just
did, getting a list of files
from the user according to
those codes you choose to
approve your application with,
you get either the entire
user's drive or only the files
that the user has granted
access to your application.
You can also update a file's
content, delete files, trash
files, get revisions
from files.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And a lot
more things are in the
documentation.
Before we wrap up, let's just
get back to the Doc.
So we explained how to build
this application and how to
run the sample, and
we tried that.
And what Alain is saying is
covered in the next section,
which is the last section
of the Quickstart.
So you might want to expand
this sample to
do a lot more things.
And another next step we might
recommend is for you to check
the real sample applications
we have.
So this is a very simple
basic application.
With this, you get started in
five minutes, and you have a
working application.
But if you want to do any more
and you still need help on
that, in the documentation we
have a section for example
applications.
So if you click on that, you
will see that we have a sample
application that is called
DrEdit or DoctorEdit.
We will eventually decide
what the right name is.
It's a text editor that uses
Drive to store files.
And we have a tutorial
for five languages.
Well, it's still six now.
Well, Go is coming.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Go is coming.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And so, for
instance, if you're still
using .NET, you might want
to check DrEdit for .NET.
And that is going to be a more
complex application.
It's an ASP.NET MVC
application.
So it's a web application that
takes care of everything, all
the edge cases in
authorization.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Integration
with the Drive UI.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Integration
And it's a more complex
sample.
But if you get started with
the Quickstart, then this
should be very easy
to understand.
And all the code is here, the
project can be downloaded from
the repository.
And it is basically explained
line by line.
So it should be very
easy to understand.
And of course, you might
still have questions.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
So if you have questions, we
will be looking for them on
Stack Overflow under the
google-drive-sdk tag.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
OK, perfect.
I think that's it for today.
I hope you liked learning how
to build your first Drive
application with .NET.
And we'll see you next time.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes,
but it was easy.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
Thank you.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]